let's take you straight live now to the
University of Boston where search and
rescue officials are holding a briefing
about the missing submersible
help you with any of your further needs
may I now please introduce rear Admiral
John mager
this morning an ROV a remote operated
vehicle from The Vessel Horizon Arctic
discovered the talcone of the Titan
submersible approximately 1600 feet
from the bow of the Titanic on the sea
floor
the ROV subsequently
found additional debris
in consultation with experts from within
the unified command the debris is
consistent with the catastrophic loss
of the pressure chamber
upon this determination we immediately
notified the families
on behalf of the United States Coast
Guard and the entire unified command I
offer my deepest condolences to the
families
I Can Only Imagine
what this has been like for them
and I hope that this discovery
provides
some soulless during this difficult time
finally we've been in close contact with
the British and French consul General to
ensure that they are fully apprised and
that their concerns are being addressed
the outpouring of support in this highly
complex search operation has been robust
and immensely appreciated we are
grateful for the rapid mobilization of
experts on the undersea search and
rescue and we thank all of the agencies
and personnel
for their role in the response we're
also incredibly grateful for the full
spectrum of international assistance
that's been provided
the rovs will remain on scene and
continue to gather information
again our most heartfelt condolences
go out to the loved ones of the crew
we'll now take questions
this was a incredibly complex case
and we're still working to develop the
details for the timeline involved with
this casualty and the response and so
we'll provide that information
foreign
so this is an incredibly complex uh
operating environment on the sea floor
over two miles beneath the surface and
so uh the the remote operating vehicle
has been searching and it is highly
capable and we've been able to classify
uh parts of the pressure chamber for the
Titans submersible let me refer to one
of my undersea experts here Mr Paul
hankin to talk about the nature of some
of the debris
thank you Admiral
so essentially we found uh five
different major pieces of of debris that
told us that it was the remains of the
Titan the initial thing we found was the
nose cone which was outside of the
pressure Hall
we then found a large debris field
within that large debris field
we found
the front end Bell of the pressure hole
that was the first indication that
um
there was a catastrophic event
shortly thereafter we found the
a second smaller debris field within
that debris field we found
the the other end of the pressure Hall
the the AFT and Bell
which was basically the comprised of the
totality of that pressure vessel we
continue to map the debris field and as
the Admiral said we will
do the best we can to
fully map out what's down there
go ahead difficult question
what are the prospects
so so the questions was related I'm
restating the question from the
standpoint of uh sometimes it's hard to
hear the question here uh what are the
prospects for re uh recovering crew
members and so uh this is a incredibly
unforgiving uh environment down there uh
on the sea floor uh and uh the debris is
consistent with a catastrophic uh
implosion of the vessel and so we'll
continue to work and continue to search
the area uh down there but uh I I don't
have an answer for uh prospects at this
time
sorry any suggestion at all that the
that the sub itself collided with the
wreckage of Titanic or that instead
instead it might have imploded above the
wreckage and then rained down nearby
so uh the question was is there any
question as to whether or not the sub
collided with the Titanic or whether it
imploded uh above and and debris uh
field created from that uh so the uh the
the location of the Titan submersible
was in an area that was approximately
1600 feet from uh the wreck of the
Titanic uh I have an expert here that
can that is familiar with that area and
can talk about uh the debris field and
and what uh the debris field indicates
in terms of uh the where the casualty
may have occurred really quickly can you
tell me when that massive Fleet will be
called back yeah
uh thank you Admiral uh so the question
is where does the wreck lie in relation
to the Titanic uh I didn't hear the
Admiral's uh answer I think 1600 feet
was that correct uh so that's uh that's
off the bow of Titanic it's in an area
where there is not any debris of Titanic
it is a smooth bottom uh there to my
knowledge and anything I've seen there's
no Titanic wreckage in that area and
again 200 plus meters from the bow uh
inconsistent with the location of last
communication for an implosion in the
water column and the size of the debris
field is consistent with that implosion
in the water column
say that this was a catastrophic closure
and I know it's early on but your
estimation
happened right at the moment and they
lost contact and after 45 minutes
uh so the question was about the timing
of the catastrophic implosion uh right
now it is uh too early to tell uh with
that uh we know that as we've been
Prosecuting uh this search uh over the
course of the last uh 72 hours uh and
and beyond that we've had sonar buoys in
the water nearly continuously and have
not detected any catastrophic events uh
when those sonar buoys have been in the
water so
have you describe what happens from here
sir in the next days and weeks in terms
of finding uh any more debris what
happens from here so we will uh the
question was uh what happens from here
uh what What's the next phase
um and so right now again our thoughts
are with the families uh and making sure
that uh they have uh
um an understanding as best as we can
provide uh
of what happened and and begin to find
some closure in terms of the large
process we're going to continue to uh
investigate the site of the debris field
and then I know that there's also a lot
of questions about
how why and when did this happen
um and so uh you know those are
questions that uh we will collect as
much information as we can on now
while the governments are are meeting
and And discussing uh you know what uh
an investigation of this nature of a
casualty might look like this is
something that happened I'll just just
remind everybody this is something that
happened in a remote portion of the of
the ocean uh with uh people uh from you
know several different countries around
the world and so it is a complex case to
work through but I I'm confident that
those questions will be begin to get
answered
uh the uh the question was uh was there
any suggestion that uh time factors uh
may have uh played a a a role or or a
consideration in uh the the casualty
here and so the debris field is
consistent with a catastrophic uh
implosion of the vessel uh again while
uh we were Prosecuting the search we had
listening devices uh in the water
throughout and did not hear uh any uh
signs of catastrophic uh failure from
those and so we're going to continue to
investigate uh or we're going to
continue to document the information
there and and understand based on all
the information we have the the timeline
so the question was what uh what are the
resources required for the investigation
and which ships we'll be pulling out and
staying in and so uh it it's too early
for me to talk about an investigation
that's a decision that's going to be
taken outside of uh the search and and
uh efforts that I was leading and but we
do have a number of vessels we have nine
vessels on the scene right now we had
medical personnel on scene we had other
technicians on scene and so we will
begin to demobilize uh personnel and and
vessels from the scene uh over the
course of the next uh 24 hours but we're
going to continue uh remote operations
on the sea floor uh and and I don't have
a timeline for when we would intend to
stop remote operations on the sea floor
at this point
[Music]
do you think there should be changes in
the way these are safely rated or
inspected so that this won't happen
again yeah the question was essentially
about do you think that there should be
changes in safety ratings or inspection
for these standards I
I know that there's a lot of questions
about why how when this happened and and
the members of the unified command you
know uh have those questions too as as
professionals and experts that work uh
in this environment and this is an an
incredibly uh difficult and dangerous
environment to work in out there but
those those questions uh about uh the uh
regulations that apply and and the
standards that's going to be I'm sure
focus of future review right now we're
focused on documenting uh the the scene
and continuing the the subform
this area
day
to help
so uh throughout the search efforts we
uh reacted to the information that we
had available to us uh and while we
continue to send it off for deeper
analysis again really complex uh
operating environment for us to work in
uh let me check with the experts but
there doesn't appear to be any uh
connection between the noises and uh the
location on the seafloor again this was
a catastrophic implosion of the vessel
which would have generated a significant
Broadband sound uh down there that the
Sono buoys would have picked up
[Music]
moved as swiftly as possible to the area
this was a uh incredibly uh complex
operation uh and uh we were able to
mobilize an immense amount of gear uh to
the site and uh just a really remarkable
amount of time given the fact that we
started without any sort of vessel
response plan for this or any sort of
pre-stage resources and so the equipment
that was brought on site this morning
that we were using was a pelagic ROV
capable of operating at 6 000 meters
cameras sonar other articulating arms
and and resources on it and it's uh you
know we had to transport it here through
C-17 aircraft this is two aircraft that
it took to get this up here and so we've
really had the the right gear on site
and worked as us as as swiftly as
possible to bring all of the
capabilities that we had to Bear uh to
this search and rescue effort uh and it
was just a huge International and
interagency effort to make this happen
so I'm I'm really grateful for all of
the responders that came out to support
this uh and and really uh you know
search uh for uh for the vessel it is a
difficult day for all of us
um and and it's especially difficult for
the families and our thoughts are with
the families uh today
but this was an immense support and we
had the right gear on the bottom uh to
to find him so thank you
that was rear Admiral John Morgan from
the U.S Coast Guard confirming the loss
of the Titan submersible he said that a
remote operated vehicle had discovered
the tail cone of Titan around 1600 feet
that's around 450 meters a bit more than
that from the bow of the Titanic on the
sea floor and they subsequently found
additional debris and the debris was
consistent with a catastrophic loss of
the pressure chamber and they'd also
notified the families and given them
their condolences so the assumption is
that the crew and passengers all died
and they will keep the robots the
underwater robots on the scene for
further investigations to try and find
out a bit more about why and how and
when this all happened well Gabriel
zondo's in the U.S city of Boston the
headquarters of that search and rescue
operation so the news that everyone was
hoping wouldn't come has come now
thank you
yeah that's right you just heard it
there live the Coast Guard confirming
that there was a catastrophic failure in
the Titans submersible and that it
essentially imploded uh obviously
killing all five people on board
immediately given the depths that this
uh took place a coast guard also saying
that the the debris field was about 400
meters off the bow of the Titanic
wreckage to give you some sort of idea
where this debris field was at they said
they will continue to search in the area
the depths of the sea trying to gather
any pieces of the debris to presumably
bring up to the surface to begin some
sort of Investigation but it's clear
that after since Sunday so pushing
almost five days now of searching for
this uh submersible they have found it
and sort of the worst case fears if you
were still coming true that there was
that catastrophic failure and that all
people on board were killed and killed
immediately in terms of
the Grim task of any sort of remains no
indication of that given the depth down
there and the uh
very difficult environment down more
than three kilometers
from the surface of of the uh of the
ocean but there's also all sorts of
questions now about how why when uh and
the Coast Guard as you heard there
saying we have some of the same
questions that we are going to start
asking ourselves in the coming days and
weeks in terms of certification of
experimental devices there's
experimental submersibles such as this
training all sorts of things now are
going to be questions now are going to
be asked and need to be answered in the
coming days and weeks and Gabe as they
pointed out it was an International
Rescue operation with the equipment
brought from all sorts of places and one
of the elements during the last few days
was were those noises that were heard
and that perhaps gave people a sense of
hope tell us more about how that played
out
yeah there was questions about those
noises that were apparently heard and we
asked them about that and it's clear
that those noises probably did not have
anything to do uh with this catastrophic
event because he said if this would have
happened they've had sonars down there
for over 72 hours picking up noises so
he said if this
implosion occurred in the last few days
they would have heard it from the sonars
sonar devices so clearly this the
insinuation is that this happened on
Sunday uh when the when the immersible
went down to to go explore the Titanic
and that these noises that we heard over
the last couple days probably were not
from that catastrophic event because
they would have heard it much louder
than what the noises they heard so
listen there's going to be a lot of
questions moving forward uh also
questions about how long it took to get
these underwater uh devices these
unmanned underwater devices that could
get down to the depths of the Titanic
they just arrived this morning why did
it take so long well they came from far
away one came from France another one
came from another part of Canada again
this is over 1300 kilometers off the
coast of Boston nearly near nearly 600
kilometers off the coast of of Canada so
this is incredibly remote area but
there's going to be questions of you
know could they have gotten something
there sooner but the bottom line is if
there was a catastrophic implosion that
happened on Sunday
nothing could have saved the people uh
that were on that vessel
indeed give Arizona alive there from
Boston thank you